To understand experimental results,
it's essential to get a feel for some
common graphs and what they mean. We
will look at line graphs, histograms,
and dot plots. Let's take an
experimental example from ecology. How
does the number of rabbits change with
time? With unlimited food, the number
of rabbits increases exponentially with
time. The amount of rabbits simply
depends on how long they have been
reproducing. But if there is a limited
rate of food production, grass growth,
the number of rabbits will increase to
a maximum population size, where they
begin to starve. What if we plot the
maximum number of rabbits as a function
of the rate of grass growth? Now we get
a straight line. Now we are curious
about how rabbit body mass varies with
limited food. For this, we can use a
histogram.
The Y axis of a histogram is frequency
and, here, the X axis is the body mass
of rabbits. Histograms can have a
normal distribution, a skewed
distribution, or a bimodal distribution.
If we look at rabbit body mass, we see
that this distribution is bimodal.
There are fat rabbits and thin rabbits
but not much in between. So why are
some rabbits fat and others thin?
Let's use a dot plot to investigate.
Here we will examine how age on the Y
axis relates to body mass on the X axis.
Now we find that fat rabbits are
usually middle aged, but there are two
types of skinny bunnies: young fast
ones and old sickly ones. Perhaps young
bunnies hop a lot, burn calories and
stay thin. Old bunnies could be too
slow to get new grass so they starve.
Further observations will be needed to
test these hypotheses.